[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans envies de lecture aujourd'hui nous
allons vous parler de politique parce
que vous en avez besoin n'est ce pas
laurent bonjour vous avez loyers tout à
fait alors c'est un angle d'attaqué est
un peu différente de d'habitude c'est
tout sous l'angle de la btp durement
d'original pour changer un peu et très
bien vouloir être un peu plus ludique un
peu dur on en a besoin
pauline bonjour bonjour bon on ne vous
présente plus tous les deux libraires à
une prairie du pavé du canal à la voilà
alors tu veux commencer avec la
communication politique donc les
stratégies de communication expliqué
voilà tout ça fait sur les spin doctors
horse est édité à la petite bédéthèque
des savoirs qui est une collection quai
paquet tout jeune et qui couvrent plein
de choses de sociétés dont les situer
situationniste donc si vous connaissez
pas guy debord vous pouvez attaquer
aussi par là donc là c'est uniquement
sur la communication en politique
donc ça va de de jfk et nixon du débat
qu'ils ont pu avoir les mises en place
des communicants tout autour qui se sont
en quart d'heure voyait vraiment pris
sur des exemples très factuelle ça
commence avec nixon
ça va donc deux avec obama aussi parce
que des communicants il y en avait
énormément et on finit forcément par
transcanada c'est passionnant et
vraiment on voit comment ces gens de
l'ombre tire un peu les ficelles oriente
un peu les départs et lance un peu d
alerte ou des fausses nouvelles un peu
partout dans les pays voir un peu
comment ça
avec le sondage comment il pilote un peu
tout ça et c'est avoir un peu tous et
ses bureaux de l'ombre mais qui sont
quand même bien bien présent et donc oui
obama aussi on voit ça voilà est donc en
décline les différentes
les différentes élections
présidentielles qui ont eu lieu aux
états unis mais aussi en france donc on
voit giscard d'estaing 74 ans voit
mitterrand en 81 enfin voila on voit on
vraiment c'est un vrai détail de
commencer deux se sont passées les
élections et la communication et les
communicants qui ont pu et christian
delporte donc quelqu un prof de
l'université de 50 ans qui a déjà publié
pas mal de romans
enfin de deux docks sur chez champs
flammarion dont les médias français qui
est vraiment le naufrage de référence et
donc lui c'est le narrateur on va dire
et au dessin basse et les dessinateurs
de dubar dakar voit la super voix
jacques chirac tout le monde est là quoi
oui tout le monde le sait ça donc un
ouvrage universitaire fait sous forme de
roman graphique sait faire merci
beaucoup laurent on enchaîne vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup
oui je la nomme andré fleury vivement
qu'on va pas faire trop trop de temps
avec faire la loi
il était une fois la loi macron alors
voilà oui c'est toujours moi donc là
c'est comment se déroule une loi comment
elle se crée enfin quel est son parcours
entre l'assemblée nationale le sénat on
peut utiliser 49,3 ou pas enfin voilà
donc là ils ont pris pour expliquer
comment on crée une once 6 alors c'est
pas tant sur le fond de la loi mâcon ce
qu'elle apporte tout ce qu'elles
n'apportent pas c'est vraiment comment
elle a été votée
toutes les arcanes qu'elle a dû avoir au
niveau de son circuit de validation au
niveau des deux assemblées et savoir
comment ça fonctionne et les politiciens
comment ils ont dû faire aussi un peu de
lobbying forcément pour que ça passe
aussi dans les différentes assemblées et
c'est vraiment très bien fait donc là
c'est vraiment un usage de ces un
ouvrage de jeunesse mais enfin
même moi j'ai aussi appris pas mal de
choix soit savoir donc c'est un peu le
parcours du combattant mais ce soit dans
la loi
du jeu de l'oie où on fait avancer petit
à petit la pérégrination de cette loi là
qu'ils avancent petit à petit et qui
enfin ouais voilà et qui va être enfin
votée en assemblée nationale puis
confirmée au sauna et appliquez ensuite
voilà et c'est pas bon
c'est très peu comment ce phénomène se
pose souvent cette question de mais d'où
sortent les doigts bah voilà on a enfin
la réponse les problèmes de nos
institutions la bureaucratie etc voilà
et le crayon est vraiment très sympa
pour les bellaingeois le dessin est très
beau donc ça apporte en plus aux
discours maintenant c'est un très bel
ouvrage suis d'accord très envie on va
continuer avec vous pauline avec osons
la politique
donc ça c'est un ouvrage plus pour les
pour les plus jeunes cette marine tout à
fait à partir de 10 ans c'est un livre
qui explique à quoi sert la politique
comment ça fonctionne et surtout comment
fonctionnent les élections alors c'est
édité par les éditions de la ville
brûlant rien c'est clairement un livre
avec beaucoup de partis pris et voilà on
apprend adultes comme enfants on apprend
beaucoup de choses sur le fonctionnement
des élections à quoi ça sert quels sont
les comment fonctionnent les parties ce
qui représente d'ailleurs chic et
politique à manuel d'action citoyenne je
dois faire les plus jeunes pour les
pousser à s'engager à prendre en main
leur destin final oui
à vraiment comprendre voilà on parle de
des élections depuis bientôt six mois
pour les enfants qui pour qui c'est
totalement abstrait et en plus ils ont
pas le droit de vote donc voilà ça
permet de comprendre pourquoi pourquoi
on en parle autant et pourquoi on se
mobilise
voilà tout ce que tout ce qu'implique
des élections alors juste une petite
précision avec la ville brûle c'est
l'éditeur des pinçon charlot
voilà donc de situer un peu enfin la
ville brûle donc forcément c'est un peu
orienté mais vraiment aussi très
éducatif
oui très belle maison d'édition
accessible aux plus jeunes
oui qu'on classe où il ya déjà pas mal
ouvrages pour la jeunesse dans cette
maison d'édition et sur le féminisme
aussi d'accord très belle maison
d'édition c'est intéressant merci
alors est ce que pauline ses week-ends
parler de cette bd d'anticipation c'est
ronnie balorre l'a fait on parle on part
du principe que marine le pen a donc
remporté l'élection en finlande le
second tour et donc présidente
tout est de la france alors c'est écrit
par un universitaire françois durpaire
qu'ils étaient
qui était connue aussi comme spécialiste
des élections américaines et notamment
d'obama et là ils s'intéressent à la
politique française et a donc qu'est ce
que seraient les premières années du
mandat de marine le pen si elle accédé à
la présidence lors des prochaines
élections
il se base sur des idées qu'elle avait
pu émettre avant la campagne
présidentielle et il essaye de voir ce
que ça donnerait si c'était millions
d'applications alors c'est pas du tout
objectif
il prend clairement en partie
claro de second tour on était donc un
face à face entre marine le pen et
françois hollande
oui c est donc là on a carrément un
gouvernement aussi
oui voilà ma vie oui
que se passe-t-il alors en fait ils
essayent de décliner le programme du
front national et de voir tous les
points pas donc la sortie de l'euro
quelles sont les incidences niveau c'est
ça la déflation ou pas enfin voilà il
faut lire les conséquences sur la
fermeture des frontières quelle est donc
la place des immigrés en france après
ces décisions là on suit rond suit son
parcours à elle et on suit également le
parcours d'un groupe d'étudiants qui
vont se révéler des secrets
il ya un contrôle des médias très fort
enfin d emprisonnement fait ça devient
des dissidents fin totalitaire nazi ne
s'est pas galvauder comme si ça devient
un vrai régime totalitaire qui est un
tout tout tout moyen un peu dit de
diversion vis-à-vis de cette pensée là
et voilà enfin c'est quand même assez
effroyable je sais pas si ça reste une
uchronie mais si finalement ça se passe
on n'a pas vraiment oui parce que
l'uchronie l'uchronie il la pousse
vraiment très très loin alors j'ose
espérer que ça se passera pas comme ça
parce qu'il va vraiment au fond des
choses et que je trouvais que finalement
on sortait un peu de grain de l'ivraie
dur à nice enfin j'espère en tout cas
moi avec ma famille ont imposé un peu
romantique de la chose l'instar bien
qu'on n'ira pas jusque là parce que
enfin voilà ça m'a fait vraiment très
peur et je
effrayant et j'espère aussi que ce sera
tout ça mais c'est que les parents tour
et enfin en tout cas elle n'est pas
entouré des deux personnes compétentes
et donc ça part dans tous les sens et
elle se laisse très vite submergés est
débordée par ses propres extrême qu'elle
n'arrive pas à maîtriser et donc ce sont
ainsi je comprends bien il ya trois
tonnes dont la présidente
donc après totalitaire et la vague il
avait juste de sortir
alors il ya une fin ce qui paraît assez
rocambolesques et
et c'est ça non oui on le dit peut-être
pas en longeant découvrir les odeurs et
on essaie ça et puis donc balade trump
et et poutine et poutine
voilà c'est le triumvirat mais un trio
gagnant
c'est ça au fond cela vient juste de sûr
de sortir d'accord ok merci beaucoup
on sera curieux de découvrir à cette
trilogie en espérant enfin bon on va pas
parler de choses
ensuite on enchaîne avec les mystères de
la vème république là aussi ce sont
différentes séries ça c'est ça ouais
c'est il ya six tome il ya trois séries
donc est la troisième république la
quatrième et la cinquième
ça aurait pu être un manuel pédagogique
sauf que c'est une bd franco-belge sont
des enquêtes policières sur fond
historique qui soit totalement oui sur
des faits avérés rassurants du factuel
et on sait décline tout ce qui s'est
passé dans la troisième quatrième et
cinquième
quand même des années 30 à aujourd'hui
un peu chaque oui c'est ça ap après sam
way tout à fait jusqu'à sarkozy je crois
et voilà c'est un vrai manuel
pédagogique
cette fois-ci vraiment très détaillé et
très beau en plus le trait là aussi
cette fois ci portent bien le récit
enfin moi en tout cas j'ai apprécié ce
ce dessin et voilà donc c'est une façon
de le consulter un manuel scolaire tout
en lisant le bénin c'est pour ça qu'on
souhaitait nous de mettre là parce que
il ya un vrai fond qui est présent dans
cet ouvrage
donc là aussi
une manière ludique de découvrir
l'histoire oui ça ouais ouais les enjeux
des prochaines présidentielles voilà de
tout connaître tout le passif connaître
nos comptes a confirmé au public une
fausse carte est en bonne conscience des
choses et je pense que c'est important
de connaître un peu ce qui s'est passé
aux éditions glénat
oui tout à fait ok super on enchaîne
avec les programmes alors les programmes
alors il y en a beaucoup sur internet en
fait il n'y a que trois candidats qui
ont présenté un programme dans le monde
de l'édition
donc il ya benoît hamon qui a sorti le
sien il y a mélenchon qui a sorti le
sien aussi décalées nicolas dupont
aignan qui a sorti tout dernièrement le
sien origines agenda très vite voilà
donc là on s'est presque une uchronie
aussi failli décline jour par jour
les jours où doit partir en congés les
jours où il va faire ceci ou cela pour
moi c'est très très détaillé avec des
notes bas de page sur chaque jour quand
on sait les 100 premiers jours de son
élection
voilà oui les deux autres sont plutôt
sur décliner qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
mettre en place c'est pal c'est pas du
tout le même propos voilà ces deux
salles
benoît mélenchon et jean luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon et benoît c'est de
vrais programmes politiques
ça c'est plus une dissertation sur
qu'est-ce que je vais peut-être mettre
en place et qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir faire pendant mes vacances
c'est une vision assez minutieux et
après les autres en fait ne sont pas
présents dans le monde de l'édition ils
sont uniquement disponibles en ligne
donc il a par contre il faudra aller
chercher chaque sportif ok on peut aussi
inciter tout le monde à aller voter
tout à fait c'est important évoque tout
citoyen dira pas jamais assez donc
allez-y et et on en reparlera l'an
prochain une fois entre un bilan
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci de
nous avoir suivis à très bientôt pour
une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle émission
dans mes lectures
[Musique]